[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
endgame class
as always my name is caleb denby and
today i am going to
continue looking at the games of bobby
fischer specifically in his historical
tournament in
a historic tournament in the 1963-64 ran
a bit into the 1964
year i believe that united states
championship where he went
11 0 and zero no no draws
no losses only wins and that's the way
we like it now in the road to 2000 i
took a look
at how sort of bobby was out playing his
opponents in sort of every facet of the
game
you know getting more activity playing
good positional chess
and here i want to take a look at his
round
one game that i briefly mentioned so
round one was against edmar
madness who again is one of those
players that i'm sure was around
back in the day in the u.s championships
playing very good chess
for the united states but not really a
household name
like fisher or reshefsky or byrne
and uh in this game i think in round one
madness was perhaps putting on more
pressure than
fisher faced kind of in the rest of the
tournament right most of fisher's games
went very very cleanly and sort of it
was difficult to find spots when he was
ever really
that much worse but madness put on the
pressure in this game
and we'll see how fisher managed to turn
it around
by trading into a good endgame so
normally in this class i skip
straight through the entire game until
we get to the end game
but i wanted to show a little bit more
of this one to highlight
when weaknesses were created and sort of
how both players were approaching the
position
so uh with respect to the end game that
is
so we had an italian game which i am
going to skip through a lot of this
because you know it's not an openings
class it is an endgames class
but there's a nice little tactic here
that fisher does play
which highlights that there's this d5
fork
if white were to capture back on e4 so
queen e2 d5
and moving straight along uh bobby is
just leaving these pieces
sort of on priests then he takes on f3
and white decides to play pawn takes f3
notably
if queen takes f3 then i believe
this would would be a bit stronger for
black because the white queen could not
recapture on c4 so
g takes f3 and this is the move
that really dictates dictates the
balance of the game at this point
so what happens when you play a move
like g takes f3
well it's important to understand that
when things like this happen
you sort of immediately are conceding
that if you trade into an end game this
is going to be a very very relevant
weakness a very important weakness
and you may lose the game because of
that weakness
so that is going to be the character of
the game from here on out
madness looking to apply pressure uh
with pieces on the board with activity
and fischer looking to negate that
pressure and get to some sort of
position
where the weaknesses will be a bit more
blatant in white's camp
and i think that's why fisher ends up
doing well
in this game first and foremost d takes
c4
fischer decides okay it's time i gotta
take my piece back
white's idea with g takes was to be able
to recapture this pawn
and notably that is white taking a pawn
back white is not up upon
it is now even material and we see that
white structure
is by pretty much every stretch a little
bit worse than blacks black has
no weaknesses all the pawns on their
starting squares and
white is sort of looking at weaknesses
sort of everywhere
right but that's not to say that white
is doing badly here
why isn't white doing badly here well
because white has extra space
and then extra space is how white must
uh that's the advantage white must use
to try and prove
that their position isn't bad fischer
started with the move queen h4
and again i don't want to spend too too
much time here because it is an end game
class and this is not an endgame
king b1 was played and now queen f4 so
fischer using the squares in front of
isolated pawns for his pieces
we see d5 now by white and this is sort
of the right idea so far white needs
to take this extra space and to use it
to do something with the pieces
so we have 95 queen takes c7
rick ac8 fischer getting active
if queen takes b7 by the way this would
be fine but then you might see
fischer going after the king a little
bit we saw queen d6
instead now rook cd8 again chasing the
queen
they repeated once and then fischer
brings the rook from f over to d8
queen e7 now and fischer takes the pawn
back on
f3 that he lost on c7
and now we have the move d6 okay and
once this pawn gets to d6
everything's sort of out the window okay
so all that stuff about white
having slightly extra space playing for
activity black you know playing against
the weaknesses
that's sort of out the window so what's
the character of the game now well
white's not playing
necessarily for activity although that
is still a big part of it
white is playing to queen the d pawn
right this d pawn is past
and it's two little squares away from
becoming a queen
and so the question now for black
is how should you play against this
d-pawn
and you can sort of arrive at this
answer
using some knowledge of end games so
chat room what do you think
how should black be playing against this
d-pawn in this game
and yeah hello to everyone in the chat
thank you for the kind words as always
but what to do what to do for bobby
fischer
it's not so easy i i would be a little
bit scared if i was playing black in
this game
um d-pawn is a little bit frightening
to me
great wolf says let's trade all the
pieces off
so there is this principle in chess when
you have
less space you should attempt to trade
pieces
and that does does hold true here
although i think
black is looking to trade two very
specific pieces
in uh very specific pieces in particular
and those pieces
are the the queens black wants to get
the queens off the board
why does black want to get the queens
off the board well
this queen is a very mobile defender of
the d-pawn it can sort of defend it
from anywhere on the board using the
long diagonals
and it can also apply pressure to the
black king
so with queens on the board white is
allowed a little bit more flexibility
in regards to the d pawn because the
queen can be used to defend it and also
put pressure on the king's side
at the same time so with the queen on
the board
dual threats around the black king as
well as defending the d-pawn
and perhaps threatening to to push it
forward even further
now what were to happen if queens were
off the board well that's where
it sort of becomes relevant to to an
endgame class
uh if queens are off the board then it
very much becomes an
argument of the d pawn being over
extended
and that is the the imbalance of the
game right now
if black can get the queens off the
board then black should
just be better in my opinion because
this d-pawn is so far into what into
black's camp
there's one particular piece that is
going to be able
to help round up this pawn and that
piece is the king
in these end games the fewer major
pieces on the board
the more active the king can become so
black is looking to trade off the queens
even looking to trade off a set of rooks
so that the king can come
into the game and successfully capture
the d pawn
with a pawn advantage for black so with
that in mind what moves
should black be looking at here
so a few people in the chat are saying
95 and 95 is a fine move but i don't
actually think it's the best move
so as chess king in the chat is saying
um
fork the king and queen on e4 i don't
know what you mean by that
that would be okay i see um so if we had
knight d2
then queen takes knight would be great
because we have this idea
but we don't have knight d2 because this
rook is there but that idea sort of
exists
i do think the best move in this case
the most principled move is actually
just the move queen e5
why queen e5 well you want to get the
queens off the board as i've been saying
and that's you know just the very simple
reason why i think this is the best move
in the position
uh as chess king did also point out this
would
be sort of a bad idea for for white
and so white is either going to have to
let
black take on e7 which black not
doesn't necessarily have to do or can
just take on e5
and after this i do think black is going
to be slightly better
i don't know if black is winning yet
because there's a lot of work left to be
done
before you can actually capture a pawn
on d6
but certainly this is a step in the
right direction
for the black pieces now in the game
bobby fischer actually did play knight
e5
but i think this move is is simply a
little bit wrong i think white has some
advantage after this
rook h to e1 is played now rook d7
is played and white believe it or not
was plus two
in this case white could have uh very
seriously put the pressure on
on bobby fischer here with a pretty wild
move so
white to move everybody what should
white play here
notably fisher uh for his credit
was still playing rather principled he
is now trying to force the queen out to
a square like g5
where he's going to take it and trade
the queens and this is a great idea
if only it was forced
if only it were forced but it's not
forced why it can do something else
so knight c5 might be playable by the
way i think someone said knight c6 in
the chat which
i'm going to assume they met knight c5
uh and yeah
that might be playable but actually the
absolute
best move in the position is sort of the
strange looking rook d5
and that would have been an impressive
find by anyone's standards
rook d5 leaving your queen hanging and
actually forcing your opponent to take
it
because you are applying pressure to
this knight what's the idea
well the idea is after takes and takes
you have a very direct
threat of playing the move rook d-8s and
queening your pawn so
how should black play in response you
have to stop rook d8
and so you can go knight d6 but now
after knight d6 once again the threat is
being renewed
of e8 queen black would have to take
this
and then white can take on c8 no time to
take back either of these pieces
thanks to rookie 8 checkmate and in fact
there's no way to actually save the
knight for black here either
you have to stop backrank checkmate with
something like g6 or h6
and then white is going to be capturing
this this knight on e7
with you know close to a winning
advantage is white actually winning
you know it remains to be seen but two
pieces in the night for the queen
is is pretty good so rook d5 would have
been an absolutely insane find
uh it was not played in the game though
understandably and white just plays
queen out to g5 and unfortunately
this is going to solidly give black the
advantage now
and we can understand this with our
knowledge of of this end game a little
bit
so what's the really important endgame
principle here well
when a pawn is super far extended like
the pawn is on d6
it can very very quickly become a
weakness
if the black king is allowed to enter
the game when can the black king enter
the game
well the black king can enter the game
when fewer major pieces are on the board
so black is using that idea earlier in
the game
using end game knowledge earlier in the
game to give himself an advantage
and that's what bobby fischer did and it
worked out very well for him so
queen takes g5 of course is the move for
black knight takes g5
now to save the knight we see f6
securing the knight and attacking
white's knight as well knight e4
and now unfortunately for black
the job is very much only half done you
still have to round up this d
pawn uh if you don't then once again
you're gonna be in a little bit of
danger so there are a lot of different
ways
to play the position i i personally
would have liked to see king f7 or king
of f8 the most
just directly bringing the king towards
the center of the board
bobby plays the slightly strange looking
knight g6 and this one's a little over
my head
but um i mean i think it's a fine move
knight can come back to f8 and help
blockade a little bit
uh but you know a little over my head
perhaps trying to keep these pawns a
little bit at bay
some ideas of stepping forward as well
but yeah i would have preferred
the simpler king to the center rook c1
was played in the game
and i think again this is a bad move
by white as i said before
uh the character of the position is if
white can
uh sort of force this d-pawn through
then of course white is going to be
doing very well
but as pieces come off the board it's
going to turn more and more and more
in the favor of the black pieces why
because then it's much easier to get the
king into the game
so these rooks come off the board and
then black plays
a really good move here white is sort of
threatening
uh rook c7 with stuff like knight c5 to
follow
so black just plays b6 stopping knight
c5 outright
rook c7 knight f8 definitely don't want
to give up this d7
square and now after king c2
black to move and take an advantage it's
it's not a difficult idea chat but
i still want you guys to uh to find it
so yeah it's simple it's the idea i've
been talking about all along
it's king f7 king e6 and black is is
just better
so this game uh i think we're obviously
gonna see the rest of it here
but this was the key turn in the game
this
five six move long series where black
goes from having a queen and two rooks
on the board
to have to contend with to a single rook
and a knight
and that is when the king enters the
game and is able to win this pawn
and that's just a fundal
misunderstanding of the position in my
opinion by madness here but
white had a good position with this
d-pawn
and then very very quickly uh as the
queen came off the board
and white was not able to find a good
continuation and the d-pawn
is just going to be a weakness so it's a
really critical idea to keep in mind
not just with an advanced d-pawn in
particular
but any sort of these advanced pawn
positions
they're going to be better for the side
with the advanced pawn so long as the
the black pieces are not able to round
it up
and specifically so long as the black
king can not really enter the position
to stop the pawn if the black king has a
path has
free reign to come in and help out then
it's going to turn out
that because the white king is so far
away it's just going to be
good for the defending side it's tough
to keep this pawn forever
the game continued with king c3 king e6
and again
we see that black is getting there first
and with authority
uh rook c8 was now played in the game
of course white is sort of making a
threat here to take
on c7 and go king d7 picking up this guy
um so rick cie played in the game now
knight back to g6
and again this sort of knight dance to
f8 and then back to g6
is a little mysterious to me but uh all
all is well for fisher in the end
king d4 was played uh and
so immediately black is not picking up
this pawn but it's worth noting that
this is going to be
a permanent weakness here it's not as if
you know the
the white king enters the game and
everything is hunky-dory
because this white king cannot really
enter the black camp
and that's again due to this pawn being
so far entrenched
in enemy territory here uh h6 was the
move by fischer just sort of
solidifying his position even further
there was a check
came back to f7 we're back to c8 and now
we see bobby uh starting to attack with
the knight as well
we see h4 and now uh
black to move and find a concrete plan
to uh let's say take this pawn on d6
right for the moment we did everything
right we got our king in the game we're
blockading the pawn
but we need a concrete plan to actually
finally once and for all capture this
pawn
on e6 or on d6
so what can be done
so yes steve is saying that the reason
for knight g6 was to come to f8 to
support the rook on
on d7 and that might be true but to my
eyes the knight and e5 already supports
the rook on d7
so i don't know maybe there were some
ideas with f4 that bobby was worried
about but to my eyes i thought the
knight was fine on e5
so a little bit mysterious to me but
whatever works
so yeah the the key point here is going
to be this move
of f5 however bobby didn't want to do it
immediately because then
perhaps knight g3 is coming with an
awkward tempo to to deal with
so bobby tries to get everything and
goes first
g6 to defend the pawn and then f5
and now this pawn is truly indefensible
white in the game tried rook h7 check
and rook takes d7
but now after knight c3 king takes d6
white is getting the pawn back on a7
but those pawns were not really equal
white had sort of pinned their hopes
on the d6 pawn and now after taking on
a7
it's very very clear that black is
better why is black better
well way way back and this is why i went
through the entire game here
way way back anybody remember this
capture
does anybody remember this capture right
that weakened
these two pawns and i said back here
white now has to understand that the end
games are not
good and so here we are
in said end game knight takes a7
why is black better because these pawns
are weak
knight g2 played in the game and you
cannot keep this pawn
on h4 if you go h5 simply gh5
and it's difficult to stop the h pawn
from becoming a queen
in the game king e5 was played knight
takes h4 king f4
putting up a good fight here but g5 and
knight g6
black has three versus one on the king's
side
and that is going to be enough to win
the two versus one on the queen side is
going to be far less relevant it turns
out
but you know still work to be done
practically how do you win this
well of course what you need to do is
push these pawns as far up the board as
you can
bobby starts with the move f4 uh sorry
a4 played by white
bobby starts with f4 check king g2 g4
the knight comes back to b5 and
now it's it's a game of both containing
the pawns on the queen's side
and not pushing too too far on the
king's side
or else risking uh of course losing some
pawns of your own
so bobby starts with a nice centralizing
move knight e5
and this is a good move for numerous
reasons number one
you're stopping any idea of f3 which
would provoke some weaknesses perhaps
by black by for black
and you are introducing some ideas of
actually just attacking these pawns on
the queen side as well
threats on both sides of the board are
always a good idea even in these
simplified end games knight c3 came on
the board
for white and bobby continues activating
the king with king e6
knight b4 played and then once again we
see the usefulness of this knight on e5
defending squares on the king side but
ready at a moment's notice
to hop to the queen side and for some
concessions
by white and here if the move a5 were to
be played simply b
a5 and if you go b5 it's not nearly
enough
uh white black would have passed pawns
on both sides of the board now
and that would be enough to win so
knight c6 effectively stops white's plan
of making a past pawn
instead 95 gives up control of the f3
square
and this is what white attempts to force
some weaknesses in the black camp
but bobby simply plays h5 and that is
enough
b5 now by white is the best attempt to
create counter play on the queen side
still but this knight just comes back
again to its centralized outpost forcing
f takes
h takes and then here the the end is
is quite simply very very
very near um knight d3 check was played
king back to g2 knight c5 king f1
uh king f5 king g2 king e5 king of two
check
these moves aren't of the utmost
importance but then finally
bobby finds a winning tactic to to end
the game can't take this guy
because i will promote my pawn if you go
knight e2
f3 f2
and that's sort of the end of the game
white tried king f3 but now he gets
checked and again the same idea
just g2 knight is off limits because
black will queen
and that's the end of the game so
i guess plan is h5 h6
um
okay so i think chess king had a typo
there
i'm not sure that anything is wrong with
that plan we can take a quick look at it
but i do like how bobby handled it in
particular
with this move knight e5 i think 95 is a
really instructive move to look at
of course the position is totally
winning for black almost regardless of
what you play in that position but
knight e5 is the professional way to do
it
you use this knight to support the
king's side you use the knight
to inhibit the queen side as well
and using the knight for both purposes
making threats on both sides of the
board is definitely
always the best way to go um here the
question was what's wrong with
h5 um for one
you might be getting forked but sure
we'll get king e6 first and okay h5 here
allows
a5 and it's it's really just a question
of not needing to allow all this counter
play for example here
knight c6 i'm not even convinced that uh
that black is winning anymore i think
you've just given up a little bit too
much
in the form of this a pawn so what's
wrong with h5h4h3
h2 uh well the the problem is allowing
this counter play on the queen's side
that's why
black bringing this knight to e5 was so
strong because it prevented all of the
counter play
on the queen side for white so it's
balancing
pushing your pawns with you know keeping
an eye on that counter play
if white have played queen f3 earlier
would black if played d takes e4 instead
of d takes c4
so yeah let me know if you guys have any
other questions by the way um
and i'll take a look at that that that
is pretty much that game though in a
nutshell
good end game play by bobby but yeah
let's back up here
if queen takes f3 i was assuming the
point was d takes c4 not d takes e4 and
the point now is that
white is not able to to recapture the
pawn and black would be
maintaining a pawn advantage that's
that's why we saw g takes f3
um okay so if there's no other questions
i am going to move on to the second
end game of the night which again from
the exact same tournament
this time it's going to be look uh going
to be an end game
between anthony sadie and robert james
fisher so
sadie is a little bit closer to a
household name
than uh the last couple games i took a
look at i think i've heard
his name thrown around in some of the
the us chess greats
so without further ado let's just jump
into it again
i am going to go pretty quickly through
the opening stages for this one
we had a symmetrical english and that
turned into
an early d4 by white
and now it's some sort of weird looking
sicilian structure
but black goth in early d5 as well we
see
a trade on d5 and e takes d5
keep an eye on that for later in the
game
the bishop develops queen b6 a6
and now symmetrical pawns in the center
and i am going to slow down in a moment
here
we see black uh purposefully getting rid
of the bishop pair by the way
bobby you know loves the bishops hates
playing against them so might as well
get rid of them
and i think this is a good place to
zenny to uh to stop and examine the
position
i'm willing to call this an endgame so
of the games we've looked at so far
this is probably the driest position so
of course
what's the big imbalance well the big
imbalance is we have a bishop
on e3 versus a knight on f6
so the challenge here is going to be who
can utilize
the the minor pieces the best and even
utilize the rooks the best as well
and for the moment bobby has a slight
slight slight edge
as far as rook activity is concerned
because he's already on
the open file on c8 here
so how should we start well it makes a
lot of sense to start with rook c2 you
just want to get the rook in the game
as quickly as possible rook d2 by white
now black is not interested in giving up
the active rook on c2
so we saw rook f to c8 and
now uh white of course wants to negate
this activity advantage that black has
with the rook on c2
so we we saw white go for rook c2 rook
c2
and rook c1 highlighting the fact that
this is actually a pin that
cannot lead the c file for fear of rook
c8 so
rook c1 bishop c1 and now
here it is in all its glory the pure
good knight versus bad bishop end game
um and that term is a little bit
misleading
sometimes so what do i mean when i say
that well we have an end game where for
the moment
especially this d-pawn is locked on a
dark square
whereas white's pawn or black's pawns
are locked on
light squares and white of course is
left with the dark squared bishop
what does that mean well it means that
this bishop is going to be forced to
serve
a more passive defensive role rather
than an
active offensive role right if for
example these pawns were shifted back a
file
white could play a move like bishop f4
and actively go after the d6 pawn
but as it stands this bishop can never
legally attack this pawn on d5
so how do you actually go about playing
these positions
for a win uh once again i want to turn
it over
to the chat room so what's a good way to
start
in this case how should we start in this
end game
so pip and chuck when we played rook c2
um
this rook was on on d2 so b2 was
actually
defended we saw rook c2 rook d2
defending that pawn
so everybody has a really good idea here
and what's that idea the idea is to
activate the king of course
that is sort of at the top of everyone's
mind
in any minor piece end game any end game
where there's only one minor piece on
the board
as the material gets less and less the
king
becomes of more and more importance uh
because
the king no longer has to be worried
about getting checkmated with just one
piece on the board
so getting the king active is going to
always be a huge part
of these end games of course the
question remains what's the best way to
do that
and then putting that idea aside for the
moment the other piece
the knight definitely needs improvement
here as well
so how can we improve this night there
were some ideas listed in the chat
most of those revolved on getting this
knight to d6
and probably they're looking at squares
like c4
attacking these queen side pawns b5
attacking the d-pawn
or even f5 perhaps attacking attacking
this pawn
and i don't think these are necessarily
bad ideas
but perhaps that's not the most work the
knight can be doing
and for example if you do go something
like knight e4
and get met with a move like bishop f6
bishop f4 rather it can be a little bit
difficult to
actually get this knight to the d6
square so
bobby in this case realized that perhaps
the best square for this knight
is not d6 looking for these squares but
rather
e6 and why is e6 such a good square
well because it number one
is attacking the d pawn forcing this
bishop or the king
you know white sort of gets the choice
to passively defend it
but that's not the only reason why the
knight is so good on e6
it's also notably filling in a lot of
these dark squared holes
in black's camp and by defending these
squares working in tandem with the pawn
we see that the white king is is very
seriously starting to get entirely boxed
out
of black's camp so why is black allowed
to play
so slowly with the knight here going
knight d7 f8 e6 in the game
well you can play this slowly because
this knight helps create such
uh you know a definitive blockade
against this white king so white's king
activity
is sort of never going to be an issue
because the king just can't invade
so we do see fischer actually start with
the move knight d7
king f1 knight f8 king e2
and knight e6 getting this knight to a
very very good square
and i think that's something that to
keep in mind here the best square for
the knight
in these end games isn't always the you
know quote-unquote most active square
like c2 it's just gonna be a useful
square
for the knight you want a square where
you can put the knight down and forget
about it you put the knight in e6
and you forget about moving it for the
next 15 moves you just never have to
move this piece again
it's super secure on e6 it is serving
a useful attacking purpose and it is
just solidifying black's entire position
e6 is the best square for the knight in
this case
okay the game continues with king d3
white does defend this pawn
and we're back to the original question
now of yes
we want to activate the king but what is
the best way to do that
so chad once again find me
a path into the game for the black king
how do we actually get there
and yeah everybody has the the right
idea here
the f5 square is sort of where
black is is angling to get you you want
to go king f5
and what do you want to do after king f5
well you want to find
some inroad into the position for the
king
so what's the way to do that well i i
really do like
how bobby fischer started this he starts
with the move h5
what's the point of h5 the point is this
is the path to get to f5
for black now maybe these other paths
were working as well
but i really like starting with h5
because it is
is already showing uh the actual idea in
the position for black
in order to win an end game like this uh
uh knight versus bishop or minor piece
versus minor piece end game
the absolute most important thing is
finding a path
for your king into the position
currently of course
there is no path into the position for
black
right all of these squares are super
well defended there's no way
the black king can break through so how
do you go about creating a path well
in this case black is looking to push
the pawns on the king's side
to create that path for the king just
continuing on here we see bishop e3
and now no reason to to dilly dally
black just brings the king
into the game and by the way we see
white
trying to make an effort to put a few
more pawns on the light squares
and now once again chat we've got the
king to f5 we put this pawn on h5
but how do we invade how do we
create more threats in the position
what's the next move here
and yeah it is this move g5 which could
be counter-intuitive to some players it
can be
a little bit you know perhaps risky to
put your pawns
on dark squares but what's the key here
the key is that white
can't force this pawn to be on on a dark
square forever
now i want to pose a hypothetical to the
chat say you played g6 in white played
h3
would g5 still be a good move here
would g5 still be a good move in this
position
yes or no
and yeah the chatroom is is saying no
and i think here
yes the idea of g4 is probably a good
one
for white why is it a good one
for white well after for example h takes
h takes
king f6 now your pawn is going to be
cemented
on the g5 square your king is not going
to be able to invade into the position
and yes uh the principle is
for the most part true you want your
pawns on the opposite color as the
bishop in these end games
so just an important point i i wanted to
highlight
black plays g5 here and it is a good
move but it
probably wouldn't be a good move if
white could cement this pawn
with the move g4 now in the game king f2
was played for white and we see black
now
rerouting this knight again he's gotten
the king into a good position
he has hampered his opponent with this
knight on e6
and now uh he brings it to d8 perhaps
hinting at knight to c6
but as we'll see momentarily it was sort
of a joke the knight comes back to e6
right away
i do think e6 is a good square king d3
king f5
and the shuffling continues for a little
bit we see f6
by black king e2 and now once again
the the question remains how are you
actually going to continue
with black in this case so chat room
once again how do you continue with
black here
what would be a better idea there that's
a great question curious thought and
i'm probably going to answer it with the
moves played in the game
so yeah let's let's talk about g4 what's
happening
with g4 well i think it's a classic
case of if white were to capture we
would be super super happy
why are we so happy well we've gained
the e4 square and that's the path we
needed
for our king but unfortunately it's one
of those cases where captures are not
forced in chess
if black for example passes the best we
can do is g takes
f3 and after g takes f3
seemingly white is holding the fort here
it's
difficult to make any inroads with the
king and
so i don't think g4 is actually quite
enough in this case
so perhaps realizing that bobby actually
comes up with a pretty radically
different idea
rohit wants to offer a draw in you know
it wouldn't be totally out of the
question but
uh let me check very quickly what round
this was yeah
this was round 11. so this is this is it
if you're bobby fisher
you're in the final round you have to
win this game to get your perfect score
no way is he offering a draw here and
getting 10 and a half out of 11. that
would be obscene
so i don't think b5 is actually the
worst move um
it's a pretty good suggestion why is b5
an okay move well you're hinting at some
ideas
of doing something radically different
and actually stepping to the queen side
of the board so let's look at that very
briefly
b5 and the point is these weaknesses
aren't ever really going to be relevant
because the knight can always step to c6
so the king is never really going to
make it in
but b5 not bobby fisher's idea and yeah
magikarp in the chat
is the first one i've seen with the
correct idea which is to actually try to
put this pawn
onto f4 why is this going to be so good
for black well looking at it
in particular with this g4 idea if you
imagine
in these positions that we had put our
pawn on f4 instead
now all of a sudden these become very
very tangible threats
knight g5 becomes a very tangible threat
and suddenly
the paths for the black king become a
little bit clear so
black in this case takes more space with
king g6
f5 f4 and i i think this is
the right way to go now for black
bobby follows this up with the move
knight g7
and to be honest i think probably the
the best idea here for black was just
immediately
you know go go get the guy with g4
after knight g7 white is able to play
this move
h3 and is able to hold on a little bit
longer
with some control over this square uh
that being said
i don't think white is you know totally
out of the woods just yet by any means
bobby follows up with knight f5
and this was you know sort of the
secondary idea of f5 f4 gives the knight
this square
and now there are ideas of hopping in
and exploiting
the weakness on g2 as well king d3
played in the game
and now bobby does get kind of a worse
version of what we're looking at with
the move g4
and i think here this is why g4
immediately was just a bit better
i do think this is the right idea for
black i don't really see how else
you make any progress in the position
but the point is could have had it a
little bit better with g4 earlier
okay h takes g played in the game what
else h takes
and now f takes white has to actually
capture this pawn
or else if white doesn't then i mean
it's difficult to even play a move here
for example g3 bishop g1 knight h4
king f1 and like it's it's
it's you're dead you can't move your
pieces you can't move your pieces just
zugged
just zugged unfortunate unfortunate here
for white
so takes on g4 is first now knight h6
is pressuring this piece and i think
here
the the game was uh adjourned
for a period of time white sealed his
next move
and the game was adjoined
so white is actually holding on to the
game here
with accurate play it turns out
had white immediately after black
plays this g4 move to open things up had
white immediately brought the king back
in order to try and defend these light
squares you can go bishop g1 here
just barely defending with just enough
squares and go king f3
and here white is is for the moment
holding on to everything
would white draw the game probably
that's the direction
this game would have been would have
been headed if this is
what had been played things are starting
to get a little bit more simpler black
has not successfully invaded
and white has put up a very tenacious
defense
but that's not what was played in the
game after knight h6
white's sealed move was the move bishop
e1
and this move is very much the losing
move here for white
it's just not defending these light
squares quickly enough
knight takes g4 played in the game
bishop d2
king f5 now bishop back to e1 and now
after knight f6
we have our path in and that is all you
need
to win in these end games bishop h4 was
played
knight into e4 bishop back to e1 the
king does
invade now with king g4 and after
king g2 uh
once again you have sort of improved as
much as you can
so what is the knockout blow here black
has done very very well so far to put on
the pressure
and we are are sort of seeing the light
at the end of the tunnel
but how do you actually make it there
so black to move and find the winning
idea
knight g3 check is certainly a move but
is it a winning idea
the game would probably continue after
knight g3 check
if i had to guess the game would
continue
you can't play knight g3 and then hold
out your hint
for resignation they will not resign
1969 five again i don't think the game
is ending after you put the knight on f5
i'm asking you guys for the winning
plan here the winning idea not just a
move
okay i think this one is asking a bit
much of the chat they're all
suggesting various night moves but i'm
not seeing
any sort of coherent idea here it's
great to have the knight on f5 you're
attacking a pawn
but of course black white is going to
defend the pawn
the game doesn't end the game doesn't
end
and yeah now chess king is sort of
arriving at the point
it's great that we can attack the d4
pawn it's what we've been doing for the
majority of this game
but of course one weakness is not enough
to win a chess game
and now the key is bobby can take
advantage of the weak
pawn on g2 as as well that's going to be
the key here so
we do actually start with the move
knight g3 check by the way if you take
this
king takes is going to be winning by
force
when the d pawn will quite easily fall
um so the king must move the king moved
to d3 in the game
now knight f5 and white plays bishop f2
but here the winning idea is to go
knight
f4 yeah knight h4 rather and
now this pawn is quite simply
indefensible
and black wins the game uh notably if
white had gone the other way with the
king here knight f5 bishop c3 this
perhaps would have been a better attempt
at holding on but here white black can
actually go
knight e3 and knight d1 check
is going to be a difficult threat to
sort of contend with
for example if you go a5 knight d1 check
uh king if the king goes this way then
we'll trade
and get the same problem as last time
and if the king goes
this way for example and then again this
idea of knight takes bishop
and f3 is going to be winning the game
um
so that might have been a better try but
king d3 played in the game
bishop f2 net h4 and now this pawn just
falls
no way to save it knight takes pawn and
the king invades
and resignation occurs very very shortly
after
so that was the 11th and final win
by bobby fischer in this u.s
championships
we do have a few minutes left so i'm
going to open it up to any questions
on this end game and then recap a little
bit what we just looked at
so any questions on this end game this
was i think
perhaps one of the most difficult games
for bobby throughout the entire
tournament uh sadie definitely did not
make it easy
on bobby fischer to get that 11th and
final win
so any questions
and well thank you all so much for
watching i've seen 280 people
on on the show here live and that's i
think
a bit above my normal numbers thank you
all so much
okay no real questions so recapping
briefly well pip and chuck wants me to
go back to the starting position which
i'm going to do anyways because
this is going to be a recap so
once again we had this end game with the
rooks rook c2
rook d2 which once again defends the b
pawn the rooks came off the board
and we had this starting position of the
end game
black understood that e6 is actually
going to be the best square for this
knight to start with
while black sort of organizes his forces
this knight is going to keep
all of the enemy pieces sort of at bay
on the e6 square
by the way there was sort of a quick
question why can't white
just sort of invade over here and i
think the answer is
that as soon as you get uh super far
over here
you're going to find yourself running
into the fact that that
black's play is just coming a bit faster
for example king b6 knight d4
and this is going to be pretty
advantageous for black with the past
d-pawn
coming a bit more quickly than these
pawns on the queen's side
also notably i don't think
black actually has to allow you to get
so far
in for example king g6 if you go f3
uh king f5 if you go king b4 what's
going on here
well you can go b6 at worst case and
then
the king will have to return back to uh
to sanity
um so that was a good question i spotted
earlier and the answer is basically
either black can just take the d pawn
or if white plays a bit more
conservatively black can always play b6
to keep the king out of the game um and
then
we saw bobby trying to create inroads
for his king
over on the king's side and that's the
way to go then
he comes up with this nice idea of
putting the pawn on f4
gaining even more space and cementing
these pawns here
to create more weaknesses in the
position and then finally
we see the losing move bishop e1
allowing this king into the game with
too much space too many threats and that
is the game
young turtle asks how deep do you
usually calculate in the end games i
always feel weird calculating long line
lines when there are still pieces on the
board
so principles exist for a reason so
whenever you're thinking about
should i trade into sort of an end game
it can be difficult to actually
calculate everything out
and that's why principles can be a
little bit helpful as in that first game
we saw this pawn on d6
and it's more of a principled approach
to just trade the pieces than a
thoroughly calculated line to to lead to
trading pieces there for black
um as far as how deep do i usually
calculate or does a good player usually
calculate
it depends on on the end game some end
games you can calculate very
very long lines some end games you rely
more on on those principles
same end game was played by two modern
grandmasters today do you think black
would still win
so that that's one of those weird
questions that is sort of best answered
by
you know uh just a range of
probabilities uh probably some of the
times black is going to win
some of the times white is going to draw
probably white's not going to win any of
the games
but depends on the grand masters depends
on their form depends on the time
control depends on a lot of things
i think a lot of the time black would
still win but definitely a lot of the
time
white would be able to draw as well and
game skills have really gone up in the
past
60 years
um okay i am going to call it quits here
uh
for the lecture thank you all so much
for joining as always the action
is going to continue live on twitch tv
where i will be doing
um analyze your games so if you have a
game you would like me to analyze
rather than the game of the us champions
uh the games of u.s champions
go ahead and head over to the twitch
channel send me a link there
and i'll be happy to go over some of
your games instead
um as always thank you guys so much for
watching this edition of the end game
class
my name is caleb denby and i will see
you next time
[Music]
you